welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spider-man miles morales is
having
a moment a new trailer for his ps5 game
has arrived along with the announcement
that end of the spider-verse 2
has officially begun production getting
us even closer to seeing miles with the
dozens of
alternate spider people teased by that
trailer months back now the game will be
a standalone spin-off from the narrative
of the spider-man ps4 game which
featured peter parker as
a mentor figure to miles but still left
much more of peter's story
to tell i'm guessing that insomniac will
continue to develop
both miles and peter's storylines maybe
leading to a future confrontation
between miles and black suit peter
because i am a grown man who likes his
toys and give me what i want
the trailers new york winter snow miles
electric powers and invisibility
his possible confrontation with the
prowler these are all beautifully
rendered versions of elements from
the first into the spider-verse film
which the filmmakers intentionally
animated at 12 frames per second to
evoke the stilted hiccuppy movement of
an
awkward kid trying to break free of the
pages of a comic book into
fluid cinematic confidence based on lots
of evidence
i actually believe that into this
spider-verse 2 will be so expansive that
ps5 insomniac miles morales could swing
right into it a crossover cameo along
with every version of spider-man we've
seen so far in the s-p-u-m-c
spunk spoofy sputnik
let's start with a quick recap of the
art designs teased in earlier into the
spider verse 2 trailer
and which spider things we're likely to
see miles morales of course is coming
back
gwen stacy was confirmed as well now the
teaser art suggested we'll also see
spider-ham penny parker spider-man 2099
miguel o'hara
and we can assume spider-man noir aunt
may could come back in
spider-man form judging from the logo
art that looks like something she might
have stitched or knitted
also confirmed is the japanese
spider-man from the 70s series
another logo suggests the 90s animated
spider-man that many of us grew up with
we can also assume from that 2099
post-credits scene that the retro 60
spider-man has got to be joining this as
well other
logo art has suggested ben riley cindy
moon silk
there's definitely a crescent moon that
was visible in there spider punk
fighter woman jessica drew the secret
wars suit
mr negative or maybe the ghoster spirit
fire suit from the ps4 game maybe
doc ock or olivia octavius and then a
real violent looking red scratchy one
that could refer to carnage or maybe
kane parker scarlet spider or even
marvel
zombies lord and miller also recently
tweeted that they originally pitched an
into the spider-verse one
scene that would have crossed over tobey
maguire andrew garfield and tom holland
but at the time
sony felt that it was too soon i guess
even more too soon than andy garfield
spider-man swing and back to those
hilarious quips after grieving gwen
stacy for like two minutes but that
pitch probably would have been around
2015 or 2016
into the spider verse 2 is coming
october 2022
that is plenty of time to distance from
the andrew garfield peter parker or time
for
us to get used to tom holland peter
parker whatever the hell too soon
referred to
and if toby andrew and tommy are down
for the cameo the spider-verse is ready
but even more than peter parker i think
we're seeing that sony's focus is making
miles morales the center of their
spider-verse
and all versions of miles morales the
tough part of a live-action spider-man
is the practical side like where do you
keep your wallet there's no room for a
lumpy old-school wallet in a
form-fitting suit you need something
more discreet well thanks to the rich
for sponsoring this episode the ridge
helps you carry what you need every day
from their flagship ridge wallet to
their portable charging commuter
backpack they want you to make the most
out of what you're bringing with you the
ridge wallet is made out of
military-grade materials like titanium
or carbon fiber it is a clean stylish
design
and it is chainsaw fruits so when bone
saw
is ready to come at ya don't have to
worry about him denting your wallet
this is their aluminum tiki wallet they
have plenty of other colors
including some nice sleek black ones or
some futuristic silver ones
it's light it's strong it's even more
subtle and discreet than my smooth
smooth segways
they make it easy to buy with free
shipping and free returns and a
lifetime guarantee it's got 30 000 5
star reviews so you know they're doing
something right they also have great
backpacks and travel bags with rfid
blocking pockets and optional device
charging batteries
you can get 10 off today with free
worldwide shipping and returns by going
to ridge.com
new rockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code
new rockstars find the link in the
video's description miles morales is the
future of the spiderverse for many
reasons but the main reason is
money due to sony's deal with marvel
studios the live action peter parker is
a title that they have to share
creative control with a rival studio
last year's renegotiation drama proved
that
but miles morales is a character that
they have complete control over
into the spider verse was a super
successful film that sony animation made
completely without marvel studios they
don't have to share
any of the profits or miles and sony's
about to make a buttload more money
using miles to sell their new flagship
consoles
this could put disney which has no huge
gaming console
and is really struggling to profit from
its most lucrative vertical of
parks in a position with less leverage
when it comes to any future negotiations
for the spider-man properties in other
words sony doing really well
makes it harder for disney to buy out
its film properties but how does all
this translate into into the
spider-verse 2's plot
well one thing that doesn't get brought
up enough is the fact that the first
into the spider-verse
already had some overlaps from the game
universe one of those suits in the
spider
cave is straight up the white logo
insomniac spider-man suit from the ps4
game now yes you could argue it's just
an easter egg with minimal plot
implications but this franchise is all
about
opening things up to all spider things
across all spider media
including from animated film to
television with that 60 spider-man cameo
and live action with that conceptualized
toby andrew tommy scene
so i think it's fair to say that the
universe of the insomniac games exists
among the spectrum of parallel
dimensions within the
wider spider-verse and that means that
miles morales from the ps5 game
could certainly cameo and into the
spider-verse 2. it's almost a no-brainer
miguel o'hara's wrist tech goober or
gizmo i should say
allows autonomous multiverse jumps
inspired by the wrist tech that many of
the spider entities used to crash the
spider verse in the comics that actually
could be what gwen stacy was using to
visit miles in the final sequence
this could lead to animated crossovers
with all the alternate dimension spider
things that we mentioned
joining forces to confront a threat
similar to the spider-geddon event
with inheritor energy vampires targeting
the spider-man of each dimension
maybe among the early casualties of this
war could be
the past live-action spider-man tobey
maguire or andrew garfield
in live action in animation style cameos
like and who framed roger rabbit or
space jam yeah let's see that behind the
scenes footage of toby maguire getting
tackled and bitten by creepy green dudes
actually before i accidentally make
myself hate this movie any cameos by
live-action peter parker's or
insomniac game miles would result in a
bit of a missed opportunity if they
didn't use this to introduce a
live-action miles morales we know
technically miles exists in the
live-action mcu from donald glover's
line as his uncle aaron davis and
spider-man homecoming i don't want those
weapons in this neighborhood i got a
nephew who live here
yeah sorry miles i'm not going to make
it but into the spider-verse 2
could introduce a new miles an actor
like caleb mclaughlin whoever they want
to lead the way as the front man of the
live-action spider-verse
in the spum kin whatever speaking of
next for our weekly re-watch movie
series let's start at the beginning with
tobey maguire and sam raimi's original
spider-man film
you could join these watch alongs on
discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars follow me on
instagram at eavos follow new rockstars
and subscribe for breakdowns of
everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign